um
let's get these uh
can you pull that clip points up on the
tv yeah taylor swift why does this have
a password
we're gonna t spill taylor swift no not
a t spell no i know well you know what's
going on with her album right
yeah yeah she like re-recorded some [ __ ]
and then uh
jake gyllenhaal took her virginity or
whatever that's not funny don't laugh
who's laughing i'm not so funny dude i'm
not smiling about that
what is cash laughing at
that's not funny taylor swift taking
getting her fake joe and all the
virginity the darkest part of that story
is
jake jones
gave taylor swift diarrhea
he fed her laxative pasta
what
that's in one of the songs
no it's not
what's the lyric
jake julian fed me
accident
she says that she sings that she sings
that he actually sings the phrase
laxative pasta
[ __ ] that dude man
i can't believe he gave her diarrhea
that's like the most horrible thing
anyway
oh yeah yeah so i think that's what it
is right
correct
i honestly don't know that's why i'm
asking he took her i actually thought
that was true for a second and then gave
her diarrhea okay
i don't understand so i actually don't
know well because you you you put you
put the laxative in the pasta
in the sauce i think but why would you
as a prank yeah i think it was a prank
gotcha yeah
interesting prank on your own girlfriend
yeah
yeah
he's like i'm jake gyllenhaal and
this is taylor swift with diarrhea
he recorded it for youtube because it
was a prank
and then you don't even see her you just
hear her the crazy thing is when she has
diarrhea her voice is still beautiful
was this part of the 10-minute 10-minute
film that she made yeah got it yeah
at the end is her [ __ ] her brains
out
and the guy playing jake gyllenhaal on
the outside like what is up youtube
that's the ending
wow what a piece of [ __ ] yeah so is jake
yeah so
he like i guess
he was dating her when she was 19 and
took her virginity wait what broke up
with her yes that was i didn't
i didn't hear that part of it
that's my let's start a rumor who cares
and he was like what eight years old or
something like that you know he was
eight years old
yeah that diarrhea prank makes sense
[Laughter]
yeah he was like i don't know 27 28 or
some [ __ ] and is it implied that the
virginity taking happened a lot of
people think the scarf that she's
referring to is her virginity oh
it's also she she there's pictures of
the scarf it's a real scarf too oh so
this is just a
it's a fan theory it's not even
confirmed
bro
she broke the uh
streaming record like the one day
streaming record she's like now the most
streamed female artist in one day
and the most stream album in one day or
something like that from this album that
is the same as another album that she
came out with that's so [ __ ] crazy
isn't that [ __ ] she's that famous
that you can just re-record her songs
re-releases them and it's even bigger
than any other album ever damn
we should create some scandal with the
original that's cringe
and see if we can beat the views
we
yeah i like that make all the same jokes
same cuts yeah
high quality audio yeah
we have boom mics and everything and
like nine more angles yeah spatial audio
yeah
you can watch [ __ ] that's cringe in
4d
what the [ __ ]
okay so this album right she released
this album
and it is it's like it's like the whole
thing is because scooter braun bought
her masters or whatever and she was like
that that sucks so i'm just going to
re-record all the songs yeah which is
that people that want to listen to those
songs can listen to my version then i
get all the money right this is a tough
ass movie oh [ __ ] hard as nails so
sick to do that
such a [ __ ] you incredible
but i thought that's all it was and so
like it comes out the same day as
aries new album and kelsey and i have an
eight and a half hour drive from sedona
you like sedona by the way
sit down at this dig oh yeah okay yeah
yeah anyways eight and a half hour drive
right and so i'm like okay we'll listen
to the aries album front to back
and then we'll listen to taylor swift's
album front to back for you
because she's a huge taylor swift fan
right and she's like that'd be awesome i
was like thought that was a fair
trade-off right yeah
i didn't realize that taylor swift's
album is the old album plus
five other bonus songs
no it's the old extended album plus five
other bonus songs that she also
re-released or released for the first
time sorry
so the aries album was 35 minutes a
total the taylor swift album is 2 hours
and 10 minutes total
i look at that i'm like
what did i just do whoa
what did i just commit to whoa
oh we did it
you did it all covered a [ __ ] cover
two hours and 10 minutes what's your
favorite song at the end i was like [ __ ]
jake gyllenhaal dude yeah
he's a dick i can't believe you yeah he
fed you that i'm a swifty now diarrhea
and actually this
we've we've been on this wave yeah we
have been
we actually were like way early to this
this just proves that we actually are
like super big taylor swift fans
[Music]
we want to get a beef like going shoot
man because it always is good when you
get the when we get the residual beef so
if you go off on someone on our show
then everyone's like you gotta listen to
what they said on part of my table oh
okay you guys get real big guests so i
feel like we should just aim for
something yeah [ __ ] jake gyllenhaal okay
yeah yeah i've heard he's kind of a dick
like the whole method acting thing it's
like dude chill out yeah you weren't
actually in the military yeah
so yeah i was joking but you really no
no we don't like him no no no we're no
we're on your side like [ __ ] that like
it's stolen valor basically what he does
to just try to play badass characters
all the time i agree
his sister's a better actor than him
maggie's
she was was she in batman yeah yeah jake
was awesome jake's just riding his
sister's coattails
so honestly a good point yeah
yeah our head
yeah
right yeah
more like ass face
nice
jar head
more like one guy one jar
no
what
damn that was a memory i did not need
yeah
god damn you know what else is a memory
don't not expecting to think about that
you saw the privilege family
perverse family oh what's that oh
brother if you just heard that oh
my god no
literally no no pull it up right now no
no no no no no pull it up right now and
just show our faces don't actually no i
yeah you can pull it up i sat through it
once already i don't need to do it today
last night oh man this is the most
horrible [ __ ] i've seen in my entire
life is this like a hr thing
yeah it's an hr
okay you know what
in between maybe we'll like
we'll we'll watch it on my phone right
before the bonus episode starts yeah so
then i can just be scarred yeah okay
it's the most horrible [ __ ] literally
and figuratively that i've seen in my
entire life don't if you're listening
don't look this up
literally literally
that's like worst thing you can say
if you think us joking about microwaving
diarrhea and sipping it as morning
coffee is bad no
this
that doesn't even hold a candle to what
this is that's my warning to you
perverse family okay
it's uh i'm watching it but you guys
shouldn't
if you can like listen to how hard i'm
laughing this is all just cope like it's
coping
with what i have seen
it's horrible
i cannot wait
it's shot so well
it's [ __ ] up
so yeah
um
yeah the scarf equals the virginity i
guess so man